wanna know what's hot in theaters this  weekend oh don't you worry about one  thing my mom my dad finding dory swims  into theaters this weekend it's fun for  the whole family and features  everybody's favorite forgetful fish and  her undersea pal Herbie the spy comedy  central intelligence pairs Kevin Hart  and Dwayne Johnson as former highschool  classmates who reunite in the world of  international espionage  horror fans will delight in this  weekend's offering the conjuring to a  supernatural thriller based on the true  life case of one of England's most  notorious hauntings and finally let's  find out what taught in theaters this  weekend with this week's fantasy patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket